the Justice Department is indicating
that the special counsels Russia
investigation may be about to end during
a news conference yesterday acting
Attorney General Matt Whitaker gave a
surprising answer to a question from CBS
News correspondent Paula Reid is there
anything that you've seen or read that
gives you concern about special counsel
robert muller or his investigation right
now you know the investigation is I
think close to being completed and I
hope that we can get the report from
director Muller as soon as we as
possible Paula Reid is at the White
House Paula good morning good morning
Whitaker says he is fully briefed on the
investigation and this is the first time
a senior official has suggested a
timeline for Muller wrapping up now
there was some skepticism about whether
Whitaker who is a trump ally whether he
just said this to appease the president
but I spoke with some other sources who
confirmed his timeline and we should
note that Special Counsel Robert Muller
has started adding Justice Department
prosecutors to new cases and that would
make it easy to hand off those cases
once the Special Counsel ceased to exist
now at the end of the Russia
investigation Special Counsel Robert
Muller will hand off a report to the
Attorney General and it's up to him how
much becomes public but House Democrats
have vowed to use their subpoena power
if the full report is not released
meanwhile Roger stone a longtime friend
of the president is due in court here in
Washington today he is the sixth Trump
campaign advisor or associate charged by
the special counsel he has suggested
that he is open to possibly cooperating
in the investigation and yesterday the
White House left open the possibility of
a pardon but House Democrats have
suggested that dangling pardons in front
of potential witnesses is part of an
effort to interfere in the investigation
so the way the White House is dealing
with stone so far has opened new avenues
for House Democrats to pursue against
the president John all right Paula Reid
thank you